foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar blood
smear and bone marrow staining manual
versus automated I am Cassie saltman of
lab roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by elitec group biomedical systems to
learn more visit aerosprayestaining.com
[Music]
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click Send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation you may also submit
any technical issues here as well if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker Dr
prasanna and Kumar professor of
pathology PSG Institute of Medical
sciences and research coimbatore
Dr Kumar you may now begin your
presentation
uh good morning everybody but I don't
know whether I should be saying good
night everybody but uh pleasure to be
here this morning
uh this is all about automated
hematology staining and you'll
understand why I've put up this um you
know this very catchy heading saying
never the twin shall meet in a little
while
uh just to get back to basics uh blood
smear is a very crucial diagnostic Aid
and I think we're all aware of it even
though we have automated cell counters
and we have this feeling that there's a
decreased need for peripheral smears
because we have a lot of automation
there could be and we all do that
fallacies and automated reports and we
do have to have a backup of a peripheral
smear peripheral blood morphology
there's nothing like it though I might
sound a little old-fashioned selfless or
hematological disorders is a very very
important diagnostic tool in fact I call
it a reflex test when one does a
complete blood count and to understand
to decipher to interpret peripheral
blood morphology we all know that it's
very very vital that we have a properly
made as well as a stained peripheral
sphere
the various types of requests that we
could get for peripheral smears could be
from The Physician they could be
physician initiated with this they could
be that we have put in a point into the
laboratory diagnostic protocol stating
that when there's an abnormality in the
counts or in the flags uh we need to
make a peripheral sphere and that
usually in our laboratory it's about 15
to 20 percent of the blood samples are
smeared and stained it could be the
pathologist's Curiosity and let me tell
you tell you that it happens quite often
it could be a laboratory policy smears
for all lymphatids for all speedometers
or it could be also a failed Delta check
and as per your isnh criteria you need
to make a peripheral spear when you have
a field there to check in certain
circumstances
for example platelets
the language of morphology is fantastic
I never fail to get impressed by even a
peripheral smear even after 30 years of
seeing peripheral smears under the
microscope I feel microscopy is still
very challenging I still feel that you
need a lot of skills to interpret
various aspects of morphology just this
morning I was trying to differentiate a
pro monocyte from an abnormal monocyte
uh looking at activated and atypical
lymphocytes in India at this moment in
time we're having a lot of cases of
dengue and we get a lot of patients with
activated lymphocytes and sometimes they
can be a nightmare because you have to
differentiate them from a typical
lymphocytes hypogranular neutrophils
more of it a little latest
granules gray platelets and what have
you
I tell my students constantly that every
slide has a story behind it every cell
has a stone behind it you're looking at
the color you're looking at the
intensity you're looking at the contrast
and you're translating whatever you see
into a diagnosis which makes a huge
bearing on clinical management and it's
needless to see sub-optimal smears and
staining really inhibit your diagnosis
I usually start my day by looking at the
tree of peripheral smears and trying to
make out whether there's anything
different in the coloration of the
Spheres and that means good staining for
example you can have a newborn babies
mirror a polycythemic sphere which is
very dark in color or you could have a
smear which looks like water because the
patient is terribly anemic or you could
have a smear which has this very
interesting blue background and then you
think to yourself has this patient being
on hair print is this supposed dialysis
smear is this a cryoglobul anemia is
this a gamma Pepe so the gross
observation of the paraffin sphere is
equally if not more important
than the microscopic um you know
examination
coming to manual staining we have been
doing manual staining we cannot say that
we haven't done it we've done it for so
many years but we do know that you can
get excellent management manual staining
but there's a lot of inconsistency it's
here today gone tomorrow so today I have
a good smear tomorrow the buffer changes
the stain changes the person changes and
therefore there's a certain amount of
inconsistency sometimes primary values
or roads and dually bodies and of course
this huge uh you know challenge which we
have in the diagnosis of Mildred
dysplastic syndromes hypogranularity may
not be that clear with a manual
streaming we do know that you need a lot
of space there's huge space constraints
nowadays and most Laboratories most
hospitals and you need a lot of space to
set up your manual staining there's a
high consumption of reagents and because
you're pouring reagents on the slides
they may be wastage of reagents
obviously because it's a manual
procedure and it needs there are so many
stop gaps to it there may be an
increased turnaround time and we have so
many other problems unique to countries
like us to the tropics where you have
stains which have to be filtered every
day because in a tropical climate you
always find there's a whole lot of
debris and a whole lot of Mark which
gets into you know staining bottles
stain the the bottles contain the stains
traditionally in perfusion use the
Romanowski stains the solution and
jimser which are what you call foreign
you have to be very sure that there's a
fast drying of the smears before you
stain never blow on the smears and then
after all this you may find because
you're doing a manual staining that you
may turn out to have smears which are
too pink to use with too acidic in color
or you may have smears which aren't too
blue
the various reasons being because you
are not controlling the person I mean
you are doing the procedure there's no
controlled procedure it's not automated
there may be an understanding there may
be an overrinsing it may be that your
water or your stain is too acidic or
maybe a vacant smear and the reverse is
also true you may have an overstained
smear there may be under rinsing and you
may have an alkaline so-called buffer
distal water or you may have a
hepronized sample and then as I
mentioned before a lot of stained debris
they make a huge difference to your
visualization of a therapist mirror
we've come a long ways since those days
when we've been using leechmanstein and
Jim systein with a manual procedure and
the icsh reference method for Romney's
skin actually says use a Pure as your
view B and and use in Y which gives very
satisfactory sense but remember these
pure stains are extremely expensive and
you can get satisfactory and consistent
staining with using good quality
commercial stains and an automated
staining machine this last sentence is
actually not even mine this is something
which I've experienced it has been
pronounced in this book called The
Practical guide by none other than
Barbara Bean who's the uh you know the
icon in hematopathology
so here it is so this is when you know
after years of you know toggling around
with manual stains we decided to invest
in the aerospray uh which is a very cute
neat hematology
um you know automated uh stainer which
uses a buffer which and you can
manipulate the pH of the buffer anywhere
between 6.8 to 7.2 more about that and
then later it uses a thiazine stain as
your bead together with methylene blue
as well as innocent and methanol so
these are the reagents which are
provided by the company
the automation of staining obviously has
many advantages
sustaining procedure is programmable
it adds definitely efficiency and a more
standardized protocol to your laboratory
procedures
obviously it goes without saying that
when you automate a procedure it's fast
and therefore you have reduced
turnaround time the luxury of dried
slides you get slides which are dry
straight out you know just like a
washing machine so you get them out and
you can just put them under your
microscope it really really helps in
humid places like ours where we had to
wait for you know minutes together or in
at least 15 minutes to half an hour for
our slides to dry there's no stain
precipitates you don't have to filter
your skin and my technicians were so
happy when I told them that from now
onwards you don't have to filter your
stain because that was a procedure which
they used to somehow have a disdain for
there are no floats there's no cross
contamination because the stains which
can't get through the nozzle and the
Jets are very very fresh
foreign
[Music]
consistent staining there's an automated
nozzle so you don't have to play around
with the buffer like we used to do when
we had the manual method check the
buffer every morning with a PHP paper
and see whether it was the buffer the pH
which you wanted or toggle it with a
little bit of Iceland little bit of
diabet we don't do that any longer
consistent staining there's an automated
nozzle which is cleaned after each stain
cycle I must tell you this term too that
this instrument has a very low
maintenance
chances of human errors you know when
somebody says well I didn't put the
Buffalo I didn't teach the buffer I
didn't standardize it this morning all
these things are kind of deleted out of
this and space constraints it hardly
occupies a space of about see one and a
half feet by one and a half feet so
space it's it's a very neat kind of
thing and your space constraints are
also looked after
appearance of course ladies and
gentlemen you know is the best teacher
we have a very high workload in our
laboratory it's close to what 400 to 500
smears per day and you can make programs
near automatic stainers that suit you
and we have played around with a lot of
programs when it first came you know the
guys the technical uh you know staff who
came up with the machine said oh we have
programs from this hospital and that
hospital and why would you try those
programs and finally we uh you know
change the programs to our needs the way
we wanted to look at our slides and we
must be aware that that there could be
changes in the support reagents their
quality of water and methanol there
could be differences to the quality of
the stain therefore you could adjust
your programs accordingly
our experience with this little machine
is that the one uh you know downside I
would say but we've looked after that
we've dealt with that as the splashing
of stains on the perusal base onto the
smears and therefore there's a lot of
debris and therefore we have customized
our procedure and I make it a point to
tell my takes it every morning they will
come in and they will do a procedure of
automatic cleaning which anyway occurs
throughout the day plus add on a manual
cleaning of the perusal at its basically
responsibly with water as well as with
methanol
so these are the various programs we've
set up PSG stands for the institution
where I'm working and this is the
peripheral smear program so all you have
to do is keep doing various combinations
of fixation intensity the ratio of the
red and the blue that you require the
spin and the end prints and then we have
a bone marrow program which obviously uh
requires you know far more fixation than
a peripheral smell far more intensity
and so on and so forth so it's
manipulating these programs such that
you get the best kind of colors that you
require this takes a little bit of time
but once you have it set it's set
forever
uh ladies and gentlemen at this time I
just take you having said this about
automated versus manual streaming let's
take you through the world of morphology
this is just a bird's eye view of the
laboratory in which I work
uh starting with newborn smears we found
that when we did a manual staining with
newborn spheres you have a large amount
of polypromasia as you're very well
aware you can definitely identify the
polymertonic cell over here but then
when you do it with an automated
steaming and I'll just try to put this
into US yeah when you do it with an
automated staining you find that the
polychromatophilic cell definitely has a
more intense color and it's more easy to
recognize versus the polypromatophilic
cell that you've seen in the manual
staining a very subtle Advantage but a
very important Advantage
number two and I've said you know I
don't remember I think this Johnson or
somebody who said there's water water
everywhere but not a drop to drink but
anyway you have water water everywhere
and in manual staining quite often you
have a whole lot of water droplets on
your RBC so you may even get you know at
the end of this meal a lot of water all
this life
and this is seed with manual standing
seen in places like ours and I keep
saying that with high humidity but you
don't see that when you do an automated
staining
I would like you to appreciate the
clarity of every cell this is a product
it's a leukocytosis for evaluation it's
a product leukemia and you can actually
make out you know the pro minus site
versus the metamide versus the band
forms for the uh or the the mature forms
you can make out each and every cell so
very clearly by the morphology I think
I've forgotten to know there's a blast
over here you can even make out the
nucleoli with this automated steaming or
again this is a peripheral smear from a
67 year old male with anemia obviously a
lymphocytosis for evaluation probably
some lipoproliferative disorder like
chronic lymphatic leukemia and you can
sow very well appreciate the lymphocytes
and that beautiful what we call robin
egg blue
um you know coloration and the smudge
cells in the background
and here it is you can even appreciate a
pro lymphocyte with its nucleus the
nucleus is so very clear and remember
this is not a gym system we're using the
tizing like a methylene blue
these are our bone marrows this is the
gross appearance of the bone marrow we
uh we we do the trash techniques so you
can see the bone marrow particles and uh
I just take you through a walk through
the body on a walk through the bone
marrows
you all know that these are the normal
granulocytic precursors you can make out
the nucleoli in the blast you can make
out the Azure flick granules in the
myelocytes
the metamilocyte the band forms there's
a cell which is an useful with orange
granules
very very clear
a bone marrow from a 23 year old male
who came in with difficulty in breathing
it was a mediastival burst and you can
see this aggregate of
query the problems very myeloblast most
probably their lymphoid this turned out
to be a T cell lymphoma and very well
you can make out the cytoplasmic
protrusions as well as the nucleus so
there's an enhanced visibility of the
nucleus with this kind of staining
versus if you were to do the same thing
under a manual yes you can make out the
bleeding of the cytoplasm you can make
out that there is a in aggregated
premature cells but you're really not
very clear about the nucleoli which is
so vital when you're dependent only on
morphology to differentiate sometimes a
lymphoblast from a myeloplast
wonders never cease uh two two weeks ago
I got had this little child
five-year-old who had this one from her
father she had the pair of first meal
very clear nucleoli the the uh the
nuclei of the blast was so deformed uh I
really thought that this looked
something like a myeloid leukemia but
the reason I said wonders nervous is
because it's it's that close cytometry
revealed that this was a b uh acute
lymphoblastic leukemia I've presented
this case just for you to show the to
show you the remarkable Clarity of the
morphology
this was a careful smear from a 13 year
old girl with epistaxis and Molina and
there's no brainer for identifying what
this is and you can see that very clear
slim uh Matchstick like structure in the
cytoplasm which is nothing but an Old
Rod
a two-year-old child with anemia
hepatitis this turned out to be an acute
medicareoplastic leukemia here are the
blood cells and beautifully stained
megaterocyte fragments have a look at
another smear and you can see the
cytoplasmic bleving though we do
describe cytoplasmic Labs with so many
different types of leukemias it's
supposed to be characteristic of
megacaryoplastic and this together with
those very well stained large metal
carricide fragments made me have the
index of suspicion that this is probably
making candidate and we do this in 61
and it was positive
here it is another Medicare USA fragment
from the same little child
an acute monocytic leukemia
this is probably a monoblast you all
know that we can't see monoblasts just
by looking at the morphology but I want
you to just appreciate the nucleoli and
I would like you to appreciate the pro
monocytes again I'll put it on full
screen and you can see the indentation
the staining has very well brought out
the indentation of the nuclei of the pro
monocytes so a combination of both Pro
monocytes as well as monoblasts the
percentage of something like 39 and I
gave it as an acute minor to give me a
probably a myeloma Moon City and we get
to get our flow results
this is one place where I find the you
know automated staining of both marrows
so very useful one knows that when one
sees a bone marrow it's difficult to
identify true erythroplas this was a
case of a pure Red Cell a plus here and
you can see that there are no there are
only myeloid cells over here and there's
this one large cell with a pale
basophilic cytoplasm with prominent
nucleoli which was a pro erythroblast
here again the same bone marrow in which
you can see a predominance it's not just
predominance the total absence of
erythroid cells
I mentioned this at the beginning of my
talk the despair of the
hematopathologist and that's the
recognition of the various morphologic
creatures which are important in the
diagnosis of myelodysplastic syndromes
for example hypogranular neutrophils so
you find that you have to differentiate
these from normal neutrophils number one
it's a hypo segmented neutrophil and
number two you can barely see the
granules in the cytoplasm versus over
here where they are much more visible
here again they are much more visible so
this very subtle
um you know uh observation has to be
documented when one is thinking in terms
of amino dysplastic syndrome in a
myelodysplastic syndrome here's a bone
marrow and this is one of my bone
marrows with a dysplastic megacharyocyte
which ladies and gentlemen you can see
so very clearly it's a multi-nucleate
megacharyocyte which is one of
simpleones for diagnosis of amino
dysplastic syndrome and a child with
chronic anemia
um congenitality disorder politic anemia
and you can see beautifully the
internuclear bridges in the large
multi-nucleated Electro blast
quite often when we get a bone marrow we
also do an imprint smear from the
defined biopsies because you know to
find about please take some time to get
processed decalcified Etc and you know
staining uh with these stains gives us
an excellent understanding of the
morphology so here it is again a
leukemia
now this is something which you people
may not really have seen or you don't
see a lot of brother I should mention
that this was a 45 year old male with
fever now this was a bone marrow which
came to me some time ago when we were
doing a manual staining and you can kind
of make out that there is a
conglomeration and aggregation of cells
which are query epithelial not very
clear this was five six years ago and
here we have a bone marrow which came
recently it was maybe about four or five
months back in which you can very very
clearly see a similar collection and you
can very well notice the epithelioid
nature of the cells here it is beautiful
you know this kind of coma shaped cells
and here and you know you once you see
these kind of cells you can be
absolutely sure that they're epithe
right
another place where we use this
technique is for staining of malaria
parasites again we uh manual staining
you know you have to play around a lot
with your buffers we have played around
with the buffer yield the automated
stainer and we have found that the
detection and identification of malaria
parasites is best at a pH of 7.2 so
we've got the pH we have another program
actually here it is it's known as psgnp
that's the malarial parasite where we
have a buffer of 7.2 and at 7.2 you can
make out very well the parasitized cells
both in Vyvanse as well as calcium we
are more easily identified so here you
are here you have the trophosoids you
can see the eosinophilic or the
acetophilic or the pink centrumia here
you have a cell which really looks
hungry it's got multiple parasites
within it most probably from a
plasmodium valciparum and you can see
very very well or very clearly the
trophy so it's also with the pigment
within the cytoplasm
we use the equipment for body fluids
also we said we don't use the site we
don't have a side to center field to the
equipment so we have a separate side to
centrifuge and then we put in the slides
for staining and recently I had a
patient with a carcinoma breast who had
metastasis in the cerebral spinal fluid
here are the
um the malignant cells in the cerebral
spinal fluid and here I have finer
nucleolar details for you to appreciate
quality control having said this about
the morphology the quality control in
any laboratory of any equipment or any
procedure you all know is very important
it's an integral part of your
standardization so the quality control
of automated style students is as
important if not more than any other
analyzer on the laboratory uh when you
have a QC failure you need to check
clean as well as reset obviously this is
a very qualitative thing there's not
much of a quantitation to do over here
in the process of quality control in
spite of the fact that the buffer is
consistent I ask technicians to check
the pH of the buffer every morning and
to clean the carusal I've mentioned this
earlier very very methodically both with
water as well as with methanol to make
two peripheral smears from a fresh
patient sample and these mirrors are
examined Bruce Lee as well as
microscopically for the quality of the
smear which means the manual procedure
with which we make this meal as as well
as the quality of this team
we have certain I mean I think everybody
knows that the nuclear and cytoplasm
have to have different stains there's a
blue chromatin lilac colored granules
and the neutrophils you know salmon pink
rbc's course eosinophilic gradules and
violet purple platelets so once these
are satisfied we say yes go ahead and
get the staining of the day begins so
quality control is very essential
I hope you don't mind if I say that I do
have a wish list for the aerospray and
that's automation of the red pillow side
Stadium because we we do automate better
the site counts however we are teaching
institutions so we still continue to
teach our graduate medical students as
well as our residents the good old
reticular side steering because you
never know you may not have it
everywhere the automated so it'll be
really nice if the machine could take up
you know could be flexible enough to
um take up stains reticular side
staining as well as for packed States
so ladies and gentlemen I end by saying
that the blood smear is part of a
medical record it's important that maybe
sometimes the only evidence of a disease
like you know of an MBS or Leukemia
Lymphoma or a hemolytic anemia
um you have to store smears nowadays we
are storing digital images and the
clinical history findings the perfect
blood features as well as advanced
investigations of hematologic disorders
make the entire kind of a package with
which you can make a diagnosis on a
patient
so manual versus automation manual
staining in addition to all the other
negative aspects of it it's a repetitive
task and fallacies could occur which
make interpretation difficult automation
obviously frees the tech to concentrate
on other procedures and because of this
I've managed to start so many other new
procedures with the laboratory because I
get we have very few technicians and I
get technicians I have offered those
they're programmable stainers as I've
mentioned before these safe space in the
long run they are economical and there's
a reduced turnaround time I must confess
that at the start of Automation in any
laboratory I must confess that in my
laboratory at the start of all this
automation there was a concern amongst
the texts whether they'd lose their jobs
and I think that goes with any sort of
you know automation
um I mean any sort of play any place
where
uh there was a little bit of you know
doubt on the management side whether
this would be more expensive whether we
would not be able to troubleshoot in the
middle of the procedure and whether we
get technological support but over the
years I think we have been able to
overcome most of these concerns thank
you very much and this is the hospital
where I work
have a good day everybody
thank you Dr Kumar for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
what would you say are the greatest
benefits of staining bone marrow samples
on the Arrow spray stainer
oh
if you ask me the greatest benefit
is the time
that I save by using the aerostealer if
it was the traditional way of doing bone
marrows we had to keep them in methanol
for half an hour and then we had to
stain them for an equal amount of time
so you know the turnaround times in
hospitals these days are so very
important and we'd like to have results
as fast as possible so the aerostena
gives me a lot of economy of time you
know for especially for bone marrows
where it can be terribly laborious and
terribly labor intensive to be doing
bone marrow stains this takes it all
over
wonderful thank you our next question
here is overall what has been the
greatest Advantage for you after moving
from manual staining to automated
staining with the aerospray stainer in
your laboratory
many advantages
but if you ask me the greatest Advantage
it's the um it's the standardized stain
which I received it's the uniformity of
staining I don't have to keep
troubleshooting every time I have a
problem regarding the steering because
generally I get a uniform staining and
it saves a lot of time therefore when
you have you know a programmable
instrument which gives you uniform
standard
material which you can try to interpret
on
okay
we have another question here you said
your lab handles around 400 slides a day
can the aerospray stainer keep up with
that big of a workload
to answer this question frankly no
because our Arrow still is pretty
straight it takes just about 12 slides
at a time and I've been actually asking
for another one I think it's it's uh
it's it's it's high time I moved on to
having a couple more of these arrows
spray strainers and that's in the Anvil
I've been asking people I suppose I'll
get them uh very quickly I'm optimistic
about that but if you answer me yes 400
slides is a huge load and doing them 12
at a time is kind of you know time
consuming
and but still it's faster than the
manual I'm sorry so it's faster than the
manual perfect uh we have another one
here do your technicians in the lab help
you define custom staining settings on
the aerospray and who helps decide which
custom stain program is the best
it's okay team effort it's it's me I
mean we have other faculty also in the
lab and we work hand in glove with the
technicians and ask them to do various
customizations of this team for example
I was showing you the newborn stees for
example I was showing you the malarial
parasite that came with a lot of effort
because we wanted to have the optimal
staining the optimal colors for
recognition of a difficult parasite like
malaria we do have fancy
immunopromatographic cards but we still
keep the peripheral smear as a kind of a
gold standard for looking for malarial
parasite so together we keep on playing
around with the programs doing a lot of
permutations and combinations and try to
get something as optimal as possible
thank you it looks like we have time for
just one more question
you talk a lot about humidity affecting
the staining I also work in a very humid
climate what other suggestions do you
have when dealing with humidity
well um as I mentioned in my webinar uh
the problems with humidity came
especially when we were doing manual
steaming number one the fact that we had
a lot of water artifacts in the sphere
number two the smears don't dry as fast
as they are supposed to when you have a
humid atmosphere around you and we've
kind of got over all these things by
moving our staining to this to the
automated method another problem you
have in human places for example I don't
know whether you're from a tropical
country but in humid places is the
settling of dust into all your steams so
you constantly and every time at least
twice or Thrice a day you have to keep
filtering your stains before you use
them now you can completely do away not
completely you can almost do away with
it by using an automated stainer because
it's there it's connected to the machine
and you don't have this problem of dust
settling into your
um staining bottles however again a word
of caution remember because we are in
humid climates maybe the manufacturers
may tell you that you may have to clean
your machine just once a day but I'd
advise you to clean it at least twice or
Thrice a day to get the best steaming
okay thank you Dr Kumar do you have any
final comments for our audience
uh the final comment is that see we've
come a long way from doing everything
manually in the laboratory to an almost
total automation
I can understand if you are in a
particular I do know how many of this
audience are my laboratory which is
doing manual or partial manual you have
a lot of obstacles on the way everything
from the management saying why are you
spending so much of money the economy of
the whole thing to uh you know employees
even thinking that they might lose their
jobs because you're going into
automation but let me tell you none of
this is true because Management's
realize over the long over a long period
of time that these kind of automations
definitely bring in a lot of economy
they definitely bring in higher
turnaround times which pleases their
patients and therefore gets them more
Revenue because you get more patience
all the time in the hospital I mean it's
this just not for the stainer but this
is for every automation so you really
don't have to be worried about the
threat of automation I'd suggest that
all if you just go ahead and start the
Automation and realize that it is pretty
advantageous where so many parameters
are concerned starting from the
turnaround time to the standardization
to the uniformity to the fact that you
can actually use your time for something
better while your instrument is looking
after your stay neutral procedures
thank you
thank you again Dr Kumar for your time
today and your important research we
would also like to thank lab roots and
our sponsor elitec group biomedical
systems for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
we did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
Roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye
thank you everybody